好 科技真的是一个很奇妙的事情
有时候你升级了
你周遭的东西都要升级
反而告诉你周遭的东西
不要用到那么好了
CPU就造成这样的现象
有人说了
CPU如果全面普及
CCL不用用到M9这么好
讲过M4就够用了
到底这件事情是真是假
因为今天CCL三雄
跌烂了
到底是不是一个错杀
今天幸好有危态来救火
再来我们知道2奈米
这个没有问题的
台电下个礼拜就有论坛了
所以你觉得盘面上的黄金右下角
就是设备跟封测
好我们赶快看一下
今天大家最关注的
为什么今天CCL三雄
在这个加权指数大涨
超过千点的时候
竟然有人中跌
甚至还跌停板
我跟你讲你现在哪一天来都可以
因为天天都有鬼故事
对
来我们先来跟大家说一下
今天的一个故事
市场传闻
CCL可能会降规
然后转向这个光通讯CPU
什么意思呢
它简单说就是
未来当这个全面改采
CPU光通讯的时候
因为呢
这个以前的这些
所谓的一个通讯的讯号
可能要通过这个
所谓的一个主板
然后传递这个讯号
可是以后呢
都是靠这个光纤
来去做这个传输了
不要你了
对 所以我就不需要
我就不需要这么好的
这个所谓的一个主板
那可能呢
现在的这些所谓的
CCL的一个规格
就会从M8 M9
直接降到M4
那么这样子的情况之下呢
那么这个大家对于
那接下来CCL
可能会面对降低的这个情况
那它的整个所谓营收
或者是毛利率
都可能会呈现下滑
所以就造成今天
CCL的相关的个股
都是呈现了一个明显下跌的情况
是 甚至盘中打到跌停
对不对
不过后来台奖台光电视
有稍微拉起来
对 好
那么关于今天早上这个市场传闻呢
这个铜箔基板的业者都表示
升级的趋势是不会改变
升级的方向有可能会改变
什么意思
就是说其实未来主机板的部分呢
仍然会朝向高层数
高耐压跟供电稳定前进
但是可能大家对这种
所谓的一个载版的需求
OK
那可能会因为呢
这个大家都包进去了之后
CPU把它包进去之后
那么载版的这个需求
会往上做增加
好
那为什么这个只是市场传闻呢
因为今天虽然说CCL
是这个下跌的
那如果说按照这个市场传闻的
一个说法来看的话
那应该是对CPU是好事啊
对 可是今天CPU也没涨
也是开高走低
对
那么对这个宅板应该是好事啊
可是今天宅板双雄
也是从早上的平盘之上
杀到平盘之下
也没大涨
所以有人没大涨
有人是重错
对
所以我觉得今天大家在这个
所谓股票上面的一个交易上
比较是属于没有这么理性的一个操作
OK
那我个人认为呢
因为这个CPO
全面性的采用了这件事情
可能要到2028年之后才会发生
所以今天的這個所謂的股價的拉軌只不過就是短時間上市上担忧这个高单价的M8跟M9它的需求可能会见点
那么有一些个本益比
相对比较高的个股
能面临到一些短线上面的修正
这是我认为在今天排面上面
这个CCL三雄所导致的一个
股价下跌原因
那么长时间来看
逻辑上好像说得通
但是在实务上我个人认为
基本上既然已经升级上去的产品
理论上不会这么轻的
去做一个降规动作
就突然跟你说不用了这样子
大家更认证半天
那我相信大家更关心就是说
那今天这个CCL
这个股价跌下来之后
有没有机会去减便宜
是 如果我们从股价的走势来看的话
对 联帽就是从头锁到尾
对 今天其实这个联帽
台药跟台光电
他们今天虽然说盘中都是下跌
但是只有一档个股是锁跌停满到收盘的
就是连帽
但是其他的台药跟台光电
这两档个股基本上在今天
都是有留下下影线的
至于说金区跟富桥
他们今天跌幅就更少了
所以其实我觉得市场上面还是有一些
就是认为说这个所谓市场传闻
大概只是空穴来风
至少在今年或者是明年
这个事情不会发生
所以我觉得在基本面
相对的强势情况之下
今天这个市场传闻
出来之后造成股价下跌
事实上是造成非常多的
这个投资人
进场做低阶的好机会
今天其实是给机会
对
很多人一看到跌
就会觉得说
这个族群都完蛋了
其实不是这样看
今天都有报非常大的量
我们现在看一下台光店
我们这个台股三本柱之一
是
现在只剩下台积电撑着
可以啦可以啦可以啦
还可以是不是
台达电和台光电比较逊色
可以啦可以啦
台光电呢
这波往下去做一个走跌
今天呢
是刚好回射到这个
就是在这个
这个是半年线
半年线破掉
半年线的位置
对
可是之前呢
它的股价也曾经回射到这个半年线
也是半年线
然后你看哦
两次有很类似的情况
第一個回撤半年線
第二個爆大量
所以其實每一次回撤到半年線
基本上它都有出現
就是去低接買盤的現象發生
那麼目前看起來
在前波段這波的下跌
我個人認為就是投信
投信在這邊去做一些
所謂的持股的一個解碼的動作
可能做結帳了
但是我認為以今天
这么大的这个成交量来看
明天要去做止跌跟反弹的几率
是相当大的
这个是台光电
好 那么再来连茂
今天收盘跌清版的
因为它之前的姿态比较高
你说的没有错
我们比较一下台光电连茂
跟等一下看的台药
现在就只有连茂
它的股价还在月线的附近
你说这个台光电
都回涉到半年线的
连茂你还在撑在这个上面
这个所谓月线的附近
所以它跌的相对比较少
所以可能酝酿出来
或累积它的这个
所谓的卖压筹码会比较多
所以导致今天联帽
是跌停板所使到这个收盘但是今天这个联帽它仍然是一个出现爆大量的情况虽然锁跌停但却有量对 还是有量
还是有量的
所以我觉得明天可能
因为它今天锁跌停的关系
它明天理论上都还有往下
再去做一个侧低点的动作
但是有没有可能
出现开低往上再做走高呢
我觉得这个是明天要去做
特别观察的地方
这是连帽
再来第三家就是6274的台药
台耀呢
盘中也打到跌停
对
虽然说大家好像看起来
盘中的股价都是相对弱势
可是我个人认为台耀在这三档
个股当中
它在高档去做整理的这个角度
其实相对比较平缓
它没有像刚刚台光电这样
是往下杀的
它是往下
但是台耀是属于有点走横盘的
横盘架构
那么目前看起来台耀
它现在的一个股价
也是回测到了
就是半年线的一个位置
对 台光跟台药涨
一样都在半年线
都在半年线的位置
但是它这波下跌的这个角度
跟刚刚台光的相比
它的这个角度相对比较平缓
那原因是因为呢
我个人观察到
外资其实在后面这一段
是有站在这个买方的
它把投信这边呢
做这个释出的筹码
全部都接走了
所以在台药来讲
比较像是所谓的一个土洋对作
那通常土洋对作呢
在这种所谓大幅度震荡的隔天
基本上呢
他們都有機會出現直接跟反彈
好
所以我覺得明天
大家看到這個台藥
或者是台光電
它如果說是出現開很低的話
搞不好都有機會
去做一個封低的承接
好 而且今天的話
感人上是盤中消息走開來了
大家才去看
要不然應該第一時間就看了
對
這個是這個CCL三雄的一個部分
是
好
那麼有鬼故事
但也有好消息
有好故事
也好故事
OK 好
研发科它最新的晶片
天玑9600 Pro
目前推出来
而且是搭配什么
台积电的先进制程跟封装
它应该是很有机会
能够做到所谓的边缘运算的能力
是 因为我一看到的时候
我直观就是又是为了手机
结果后来围台就说
这就是边缘AI
大家都要从云到端的
对 所以在这样子的情况之下
它至少在我们所谓的手机晶片
或者未来的这个手机的一个发展上
目前看起来联发科仍然是遥遥领先
那么赶快看一下
在这样子先进论坛的这个之前
有没有哪一些的一个公司
或者产业可以特别去做掌握
今天就不一样了
这一块是红东东
虽然也是有点涨势压抑
但他们其实以前8月的累计营收来说
成长率不算太高
说得好
这就是我现在认为
封测除去我们会优先去做观察的地方
黄金右下角觉得真正的黄金在这个地方
因为在过去AI相关的这些的次族群
不管是散热
不管是CCL PCB等等的
他们的成长幅度都超级大
都爆喷有什么三位数破百的
那这里面我觉得其实有一些股价
已经修正过的在右下角的公司
可以特别做留意
谁呢
哎呦 难冒记忆体相关的
对 记忆体相关的
那最近记忆体的这个热度又开始做增加
所以記憶體相關的封測
我覺得大家是可以特別做留意尤其是南茂它社會到AI伺服器所帶動的高階的记忆体低润跟DDR有风湿需求大幅度的一个提高所以目前看起来在整个股价
在这边就进行横盘性的整理
似乎收敛接近尾声
也在半年线
对 而且现在大户的持股
在最近这两周
有出现往上做增加
那么最近的股价
通常技术指标在低档的
比较会涨
对耶
就突然之间一根上
大家基本面都差不多
但是基础指標在低檔也比較會漲
所以像南茂現在的KD指標
已經回測到了大概在27的位置了
21跟27的位置
所以其實未來這兩天
大家可以特別做留意跟關注
這個是南茂
再來就是華東
它在所有均線下
怎麼時間跌成這樣了
42塊
同盤股
43塊
那為什麼挑華東呢
最主要跟剛剛這個
這個新福哥所提到的華邦店
你們兩個今天是對稱的講法
他講華邦店
對 CPU講到這個CCL
然後對 上游講到下游
是 我們來看一下
因為華邦店收購英飛林旗下的
No Flash跟FRAN的事業
100%的一個股權
那華東又是跟華邦店同集團的封測
所以我認為說接下來
他有可能會接收到一些所謂外衣的訂單
所以目前的股价
它的股价拉軌在这个地方
季度指标也在相对低档
要往上去进行黄金交叉
股价也相对比较便宜
好 可能大家都看什么日光晶圆店
反而今天帮大家看了两档百元以下
未接超低的封测
没错 整理到接近尾声
好 再来就是这个制程
这个制程 先进制程封装设备相关的一个个股
好 设备就很不一定
有人成长九成
有人成长可能两成不一样这样子
对
那因为他们主要所这个
focus的一个产品不太一样
所以这边一样先帮大家
在这个时间点
帮大家挑一些股价
已经做过修正的一个标的
好
6640的君华
君华
G2C联盟
对
这个就是COA相关的一个设备
OK
它的精力挑减机
市占率是很高的
而且拉货是非常的强劲
那么在最近可以观察到股价在这边去做整理
然后呢 投信
投信在这边已经开始出现
开始说布局了
OK 好
同样的KD指标在这个地方呢
已经回测到相对低档的位置
所以我觉得短时间之内
也可以特别去做一个留意跟观察
而且看起来可以买得比投信便宜哦
有这个机会
差不多
对 差不多的成本
OK
再来呢就是这个6196的樊轩
他今天没表现
对 他今天没表现
它现在股价在高档做强势整理
也不太想要下去的样子
对
所以原因就是因为
通常这家公司在第四季
它都有这个工程款要进入
这个任务入账的高峰期
那现在在手订单1347亿
是
OK
现在看起来量缩缩链到尾巴
KD指标也随时有机会
要往上去进行交叉
是
大家真的不要看设备股在很绵
很洗的时候不理它
对
因为第四季
尤其是11 12月份的時候
入账高峰
這個就跟剛剛講到的
第四季漲率一樣
都幾乎是一個鐵打的事實
沒錯
好 這邊非常謝謝薇泰